we have a few questions kind of targeted
into the panelists rather than everybody
answering all of the questions but I
want to start with Jim Jim yang is a am
class of 97 it recently purchased a cold
stone franchise run right over here at
Town and Country and when I last spoke
with you were contemplating buying
another one as well I should have opened
up two more okay more cutting them out
right now okay so that doesn't go well
with myself Beach diet but we won't go
there as a relatively new franchise
owner do you talk about the process that
you went through identifying and
selecting a franchise yeah so I mean I
think the different attacks I can take
with this one may I think you know
probably most relevant for this audience
is 5 to sort of discuss some of the
philosophical you know underpinnings of
what happened here so so I collect a lot
of you or school today you know I was
really fired up about you know leaving
the business school here and going off
and do some really exciting things a lot
of you have been going to the high tech
industry which is what I ultimately
ended up doing but what I found that
Frank laughter now I graduate 97 with
the Netscape and from day one one of the
things that sort of you know began
plaguing me was this notion that I was
increasingly stuck in this rat race and
you know you know the whole proverbial
working for the man and any second a
situation where you know there's no
clear exit unless you fortune enough to
to pick the right startup company the
hits at IPO pop right and so you know
you know I dealt with this malaise for a
couple of years and and you know started
thinking about different way to get out
of this and so ultimately you know after
sort of kicking around a bunch of
different ideas for the last several
years I had you know a minor epiphany
last last summer which was you know one
way to sort of get out of this this rat
race and try to attain some semblance of
financial independence and by that I
really mean and not so much material
wealth first own sake but really you
know having the flexibility to do
whatever I want to do that worry about
sort of my financial obligations I
started thinking about you know you know
one way for me to get there was to
really sort of recast the way I manage
my ass
portfolio so to date I had been you know
you know plowing all my resources into
what would really cashflow absorbing
assets or things like you know how some
card and these are all things that are
great for an appreciation standpoint but
don't really throw off cash and
obviously things that you can live off
and so you know this minor epiphany I
had was really about we recast in my
asset allocation to be to towards more
assets that tend to be cash flow
generated so things like you know
commercial residential real estate
properties or small businesses and I
thought well that could be an
interesting way to go and the great
thing about this financial system that
we live in is if you get into a business
that can demonstrate in a reasonably
stable in predictable cash flows the
banks will line up to let you more money
which you can then use to either expand
your business or go out and buy other
businesses or other properties and the
cycle just goes on and on and it's how
you know people like Donald Trump have
been able to dig themselves of these
massive holes by basically using the
financials in the lending system to
really you know lever themselves from
you know up and up to the point where
you know they have more than enough
money coming up with the operations to
fund their lifestyle along with the
management and operations of their
businesses and so I really thought about
doing a restaurant so something like an
Applebee's but more of like a scale of
stand-alone type of entity you know I
spent some time in New York and Boston
pre Business School so there are a
number of concepts I thought they would
be really well here in Palo Alto and the
more I researched it the more I realize
the odds were against me because you
know in the restaurant business that
some of you may know it's very very
high-risk so so eight out of ten to fail
within eighteen months the cab would
require to open one of these up
especially the kind of scale that I was
thinking are pretty pretty formidable I
mean you know I was looking at you know
seven figures plus to open up something
that you know for in all I knew could
you know even with the best intentions
and what the staff would fail and then
third and perhaps most importantly you
know you know like many of you I had no
idea how to run a restaurant and and no
business trying to do it on my own and
so I realized you know two or three
things coupled together or you know
don't add up to success so you know for
me you know I decided to scale back my
expectations and my thinking a little
bit and and came to this notion of a
franchise and so you know to be honest I
had always had sort of a you know I
don't know a negative but
not a positive you know connotation with
with with with franchises because
something that you know from my
perspective you don't necessarily you
know need to invest you know hundred
thousand dollars in your MBA education
to go do it you could really just do it
straight out of high school and so you
know it wasn't something that I thought
would be a great way to sort of build my
career but but uh but ultimately I feel
like franchise was a good way to go
because you know they tend to be you
know a lot lower risk than trying to do
something on your own
right because the concept to prove it I
mean there are people who have spent
years tweaking the formula to get it to
work and the risk is a lot less about
market risk and a lot more about
execution resume and that was something
I felt like you know I could handle or
people I could hire to handle
um secondly how do you end up picking
Colts down so so you know for that I
really wish I could say for this
audience that it was a result of a
comprehensive and exhaustive but it
really it really was it so you know I as
when I decided to do the franchise thing
there were there was really only one
that I really thought of that was close
to him and the reason was I I had been
to you know I think three quote zones up
to I've ended I think three courses up
to that point and every single one I had
been to headlines out the door one was
in Honolulu one was in Palm Springs
another one was in LA and and I just
sort of stuck in my mind right that that
was a concept I could do really well up
here and so it's really sort of like the
Warren Buffett approach to investment he
doesn't analyze the numbers to death he
doesn't you know go out and subscribe to
you know the hundreds of different
research reports basically he likes to
product he likes to management team is
going to go out and buy the stock so you
know that's how I really settled on
Coldstone and you know with the benefit
of hindsight I probably would have done
you know more analysis of the local
trade area of the demographics of Palo
Alto you know talk to more franchisees
their whole budget circumstances are on
why it didn't but but actually and we
can we can talk about this you know
later on when we talk about new or
existing franchise I actually was
originally trying to open up a new
franchise in the Bay Area but as with a
lot of franchise doors they will
actually give you territorial rights and
so you know as I was looking for new
locations to put
store there were existing franchisees
who even though they didn't have stores
had the territorial rights to the
location so I was really locked out and
you know really persisted for about six
months it was about to give up when they
approached me and said hey we have a a
corporate owned store in Palo Alto that
you know we are now looking to transfer
to a local owner operator and is it
something that you're interested in and
at that point I mean you know I've been
a yeah I think of here is you got a dog
chasing a school bus and what happens at
the dog actually catches the school bus
I don't think he knows and in all all
this time I've been trying to get a new
franchise and all of a sudden they said
hey you could have this one if you want
it and you know I was really kind of
stumped and had to think about it and
and to be honest I I had to look for
reasons not to do it i dissected the
numbers to death I talked to berries
people that I trusted and ultimately to
be honest are looking for a reason not
to do it and they couldn't come up with
one you know by then ax you know I have
been doing pretty senior stuff in the
software industry and then and I wanted
to make sure that you know if I did this
I could go back in the software and
without missing a beat and and the
people that I worked with assured me
that that wouldn't be a problem it's
ultimately I said you know what the hell
just go ahead and I'm Mike right I said
what the heck and you know I went for it
and it's actually almost embarrassed to
say this but it's probably you know you
know but totally serendipity that the
best decision I've made because not only
has it sort of gotten me on this path of
towards you know what I view is
entrepreneurialism but it's really
emboldened me to do a lot more things
and that standpoint is great but but but
you know just as a side note it it's
funny like you know neither my wife nor
my my mom are very pleased by this
coaching thing because they're
embarrassing when people people ask my
mom what I do for a living she lies she
does not want to tell them that she
raised her son to manage an ice cream
store
that's one of the challenges I run into
the my own family now are you because
you mentioned a few your goals in terms
of some financial freedom I mean are you
on track to achieve some of that the
time for me we're looking at yeah so I
think I had three goals getting into
this and decided to sort of my my
philosophy in my religion but one
certainly was financial so I wanted to
reach a point of self-sufficiency and so
you know my goal was the Poston at the
time at least here was as far as when
the California coast which is Fresno to
war again probably like number seven or
number eight in the state my goal was
now definitively you know with the
bullet get to number one and really be
the top producing store in Northern
California and I wanted to really crank
up sales so because they had corporate
management in place up to that point it
really felt like you know with the kinds
of learnings I've had in the real world
plus with my my my MBA training I really
should be able to Ratchet it up and from
that standpoint we've been very
successful so you know I don't mind
saying that within six months we were
now that the top-performing store in
California and you know we're just
driving it more and more and I think a
lot of the synergies that are now going
to be created by opening up additional
franchises in the area I think are just
going to increase performance even more
but another financial goal I think to
other kinds of goals I had were we're
psychic goals so you know this is really
about you know being able to derive some
level of gratification around what
you're doing I mean ice cream is
fantastic right because it is very for
fun very social occasion I mean get
family coming in we have friends coming
in we get you know people coming in on
dates and it's very much embedded in
intertwine with the community and has
really provided a good platform for me
to do a lot more of the outreach that I
wanted to do so for example I I've been
teaching part-time at Powell to high
school right so one of my longer-term
goals is to get back in teaching
full-time and it provides an opportunity
give me the flexibility to go into these
environments and do what I want to do in
the same time actually serves my world
very well because it just so happens
that you know from an employee base I'm
drawing from poly high and gun high
school and so it actually actually works
out pretty well
I got your comment that you no longer
have your day job well I mean that's an
interesting topic so so so in the grand
scheme of things the beauty the beauty
of getting the small businesses and you
know franchises the way you go to scrape
is that it gives you a lot of self
sufficiency in
penance to do whatever you want to do
and so I reach a point in November where
you know got my store operating as well
as it could did all the sales and
marketing all the operational things and
you know then got the ball rolling on my
other two stores hired the brokers and
architects and I wish a point in late
November where I was just flat out bored
and looking for things to do and from a
resource standpoint there's only so much
I can do in parallel so I started you
know I put it out a couple enquiries and
then before you know it I ended up in a
job that I really love doing but I just
literally just started this week but but
almost I was considering whether or not
I should tell that to people because I
think there's something very romantic
about being a small business owner and
not having to worry about anything else
but but the reality is what it's done is
given me the opportunity to to to do a
job that I'm really fired up about and
excited about doing and you know which
is in contrast to previous jobs I've had
post business school where I kind of
felt like I had to do it because you
know I have these mortgage payments and
car payments and just you know the whole
you know all the risk and turmoil of
leaving from one job to another you know
it just made you know life very
unsatisfied um great you have how many
Applebee's 87 87 okay do you know where
they all are I've been to all
Jonah's good at Babel um can you talk
about how you got to the poetry actually
you had 87 a police did you grow into
them or how did you Oh both organic
growth in acquisition okay God it was
very different to Rebecca I was really
deliberate about it and I had a
commercial real estate business I
started out of Stanford in 94 and that
was doing fine toward the late 90s and I
was very interested in finding a hedge
to it you know something that was going
to survive the coming recession whenever
it was and so in 98 you know I started
another thing happened in the 90s which
there developed a market of securitized
franchise finance for short top-tier
concepts and top tier means you know
more than 500 units successful you know
it's McDonald's Wendy's Applebee's
Chili's you know there's only a dozen to
qualify but what you could do was borrow
you know almost all of the price of you
know acquiring or developing a top-tier
franchise unit at you know debt rates
reflective of a much less risky
investments like real estate and so in
Washington State where I had some office
buildings the Appleby's market came up
for sale
I had eight units they were not
performing well in the existing
franchisee who was out of Chicago wanted
sell because he couldn't make any money
there's very high-cost environment very
similar to California but I looked at
them and thought that we could do better
and also I thought when you look at the
lifecycle of franchise groups in
Applebee's and this is probably true in
many concepts you need to achieve
critical mass in a market for sale to
really start taking off so I thought
that based on sort of surveying the only
50 franchise groups out there but based
on surveying them that this market was
just about to turn the corner you know
what I got to 10 units 12 units and that
proved to be true so I bought the market
you know for 14 million dollars in
ninety and I borrowed twelve point nine
of it
at 8% and the interesting arbitrage
opportunity was you buy franchise
businesses like businesses reflective of
the very high level risk you know
therein so you buy on a multiple of EBIT
da in this case of six right whereas you
borrowed you know 90% at 8% so you're
getting under leveraged yield of 16% and
you finance almost all of it at eight
you know it's almost an instant return
of your equity it's an anomaly that has
corrected somewhat since you know as
most of the securitized lenders have in
fact gone bust as they deserve to do but
you can still you know you can still
from legitimate banks in the franchise
business borrowed 70% or 75% at now 5%
right which is still a good spread for
them and you're still able to buy
franchises at five six times keep it
done so yeah it's still exist someone's
wrong obviously they're selling too
cheap or they're lending
too much but I don't care right I mean I
get about the difference so we bought
those first date you know we grew
volumes pretty significantly over the
years and started building units and
then I started buying other markets in
much the same way so now we're in Ohio
Indiana and New Jersey and Delaware in
addition now how involved are you with
the management or how is your management
structure yeah I'm the CEO which is the
second most important position in the
company and the CEO whoa is the most
important and we're set up with market
presidents running day to day operations
in each market they roll up to a chief
operating officer who you know is really
responsible for a whole variety of
things but one is you know sharing best
practice as developed between all the
different regions around the country and
the other franchise you know Applebee's
markets out there what I do is you know
strategy finance real estate senior
staffing and franchisor relations which
are very extremely important in this
business now given your real estate
business how much of your mind share
does the Appleby's consume relative to
the rest here about half okay
interesting
now I'll ask you this specifically given
the real point I mean do you find that
the reduced risk and responsibility of
being a franchisee is worth the
trade-off compared to being the
franchisor
yes I sent her this question I think
this is the key question I've seen
probably a dozen examples of people
trying to start retail businesses and
they get all excited about you know how
creative it is and all the challenges
and this and that and it is more risky
and therefore more rewarding if you
succeed but your chances of success are
so much smaller than joining a system
like Applebee's where you know over
1,600 units they have figured this thing
out and as Jim said it's about execution
so our job is very simple you know we
need to be perfect at execution and you
know that's a goal I can get my arms
around and it's it we don't need to be
creative someone else is creative we
don't need to worry about you know our
competition even that much we worry
about them in a real-estate sense but
not you know in the big pictures and
that we trust our franchise or they are
in fact top-quality and if you think
about getting into this go for the best
kind of ties you get your hands on and
pay for it how do you know which is the
best franchise well you know you would
judge a systems performance by the
normal metrics you know growth
profitability market share an Applebees
is bigger than Chili's and Fridays
combined which are it's two big
competitors nationally I didn't all I
saw you guys this I mean Jim made the
comment I think it's a common perception
that you don't need to invest $100,000
in the MBA to go be a franchisee you can
go do that right out of high school I
mean what's kind of your reaction to
that ah it's not true in many systems
because you for instance Applebee's has
50 in the whole world right so they
won't let someone who's not already
deep-pocket experienced businessman in
the system or person sorry in other
systems like the Burger King I was
briefly a Burger King franchisee and the
contrast between the student systems was
great in Burger King it's the
old-fashioned sort of onesie Tuesday mom
and pop sort of that you know
this is your story and this is someone
else's store and it's rife with conflict
which cannibalization issues all the
time
there's inconsistent operations there is
constant mistrust between the franchisor
on the franchisee the alternative which
was really pioneered by Applebee's and
now is probably the more common model is
a development territory as you said so
we have exclusive development rights and
responsibilities in each our markets and
we have agreed to build X units over X
years you know nationwide and they'll
hold us to it but we never worry about
cannibalizing you know anyone except
ourselves and we make that conscious
decision frequently we never worry about
the store next door being poorly
operated because it's ours and we can
take care of it sometimes they are but
you know at least it's our fault and it
solves a whole host of problems now do
you have somebody in each market that
those site selection or how do you guys
do that you know right now Lauren
Cortina who is GSB 1893 is doing most of
our site selection okay yeah and um you
know I I see oversight too because
that's really mine that's really
interesting well John has been in the
franchising business probably the
longest of everybody up here with
varying kinds of experiences and has
been a franchisee for Sylvan Learning
Center can you talk about what has kept
you involved and re-involved and
franchising obviously it's been
interesting enough to keep you hanging
hanging around for a while well or I
didn't have a choice
yeah I bought I graduated 84 I was
working at hewlett-packard
and first year is exciting and after
that the job wasn't passing the shower
test I was just not thinking about it
when I got up in the shower didn't do
did not again do a as deep a search as I
should I saw an article in Entrepreneur
Magazine looked interesting and I bought
one Sylvan franchise in Stockton and
five more in San Diego for me it was
sort of an overnight success after about
13 years
I mean Greg's point is very good I
thought I was buying it at the
inflection point in terms of the
penetration and the national presence of
the brand and I was about 5 to 10 years
too early so I sold my other five in San
Diego retained the one in Stockton
frankly because nobody would take it off
my hands and return back to the high
tech industry and it manages part-time
and luckily the past five or six years
it has become quite profitable so
provides me a nice cushion when I get my
enforced sabbaticals from the high-tech
industry from time to time one of the
issues I want people think about is when
you go into is what is your exit
strategy if you're incredibly successful
you don't have to worry about it too
much you own 100 franchises the only
only couple it's a fairly illiquid
business as pointed out the ratios you
can get if you get a good cash flow
going that's great but the multiple you
can get is often not it's not what you
see in public markets obviously it's
also not very liquid in terms of your
time and your ability depending on the
number you have the skills required you
can get yourself trapped for a while in
there where you sort of you know it
would talk about propolis growth you
know you're making sort of enough money
and you think it's worth enough you
don't want to walk away from it but I'm
trapped it's not growing what do I do
and I would also consider what industry
you're in compared to where you might
want to be if it does not succeed so I
return to the high tech industry have
been there for 12 years but the first
couple of years I had a bit of a tough
time trying to sell you know what did I
learn in this period I mean apart from
obviously psychic benefits and financial
rewards I mean what are you developing
your career I mean part of it is an
industry knowledge part of its contacts
part of its managerial experience now
the managerial experience was incredible
I mean the first week I made more
decisions than I did at Hewlett Packard
I mean it was wonderful I mean I had the
greatest time but I was not really
developing industry experience and I was
a time in my early 30s where I would
have been developing broad contacts in
the high-tech business which I wasn't
really doing so to some degree when I
went back to the high tech industry that
five years was a bit of a bit of a hole
in my career so you know you have to
pick something obviously that matches
your passions but I would think a little
bit about your exit strategy if it
doesn't work how are you then going to
play this into what has to come next if
you have to go back to working for the
man can you talk about the implications
of being in a service franchise as
opposed to a product franchise yeah well
you know of course everybody thinks
everybody else's job is harder so I
think mine is harder than their but it's
uh I believe it's somewhat more
difficult duplicating I had six
franchises a little bit more difficult
we don't really have a product I mean we
have an educational system but the
growth of the center is largely
developed and based on the director the
person that's working with the parents
they're like a principal of a private
school and to scale that out can be more
challenging you have to think ahead of
time that we do back to your question
about the difference of that MBA and we
have a higher opportunity cost by going
to a franchise and so you generally do
have to own multiple centers to make it
worth your while where somebody else
might be happy at owning one and making
60,000 a year so you have to look at
what are your skills to get the first
one going and then ultimately are there
skills you can buy in the marketplace
when the economics of the sylvans back
in the late 80s I couldn't really pay
the best educators to come and work for
me and so I struggled now as we've done
better I can now pay people a very
competitive salary to what they're
getting as educators and I can hire the
best people and so it's you know it's a
standard chicken-and-egg you know what I
invest enough in the people that's hard
this is not you know a spreadsheet I'm
running this is cash out of my bank
account and it's tough to pay somebody
10 grand
for a year when you don't know you know
they could leave next month or ruin your
business for six months so again there's
a lot of areas where it's much you're
dependent on smaller numbers of people
which can make it very good and very
risky I'm kind of asking a question
where I think I've heard a lot of the
answers but it for each of you has this
felt like an entrepreneurial route or
does it feel like you're you're working
for a larger company yeah I mean I can
speak for myself and it absolutely feels
entrepreneurial along a few different
dimensions so you know to make that
transition from you know working for the
man to doing your own thing I mean it's
I mean it's a serious chasm across in
there so I mean I take the level of
exhilaration and gratification you get
from you know calling the shots right
and basically being accountable for all
the both sort of crucial decisions as
well as all the minutiae I mean it's
definitely a completely different
mindset from a skill standpoint throat
you know I view you know getting it to
the franchise world as an X to the first
step towards you know building something
grander if that's what your your goals
are because you learn how to do a lot of
the blocking and tackling that you mean
you would learn anyway and sort of
trying something a lot grander but but
it's nice to sort of you know have you
know kind of a little laboratory if you
will where you can experiment with
different types of approaches everything
from you know the basic things like you
know what's the best way to organize
your your entity what's the best way to
you know what's the best way to go out
and negotiate really good deals for your
payroll services and a lot of your other
administrative expenses as well as like
how do you deal with human resource
management right so so you know a lot of
people told me coming out coming into
business school that HR was probably
like the most important thing you can
learn how to be school and right and I
could I can see how that's particularly
relevant in the world that that we live
in the people you hire probably more
mature responsible but let me tell you
you know it's a different world
altogether when you're you know hiring
and staffing you know high school
juniors who really only care about a
couple of different things and none of
them are aligned with your business you
know it takes it takes a while to get
used to frankly I mean and I I remember
I mean I would pull my hair I mean you
have kids so we look at historical sales
data and and staff accordingly based on
in weather patterns and historical sales
and so we you're very precise and number
people use happen you have a kid call in
an hour before her shift say oh I got
concerts too a ticket tonight so I'm not
coming in right and you don't deal with
that in the professional world right I
mean you assume people going to be there
but they lie yeah exactly but but I
think in terms of like helping you deal
with those types of issues and learning
and helping for me it definitely helped
me gain an appreciation that that there
are very different types of people in
the workforce and I think here in
Silicon Valley you tend to expect a
certain caliber of person and you know
you know I think that doesn't really
reflect reality and I think when you get
into a world such as franchises as well
in other businesses that you're doing on
your own I mean I think one of the
realities is that you really dealing
with people at all different levels and
all different levels of ambition and so
this has been really useful for me and
helping me tour from an emotional
standpoint you know handle it a lot
better now Greg what advice do you have
for somebody who might aspire to own
multiple locations of a franchise what's
that's kind of a good way to start and
growing into that I am every guy
recommend doing perfectly seriously if
you recommend doing one one to start
with err it's a more difficult way to do
it and I don't think the rewards are any
greater if you can pull it off you know
by scale and grow from there there are
great scale economies in this business
there is great financing available in
this business let me comment at this
point I think any activity in which you
have a 100% interest in the bottom line
feels entrepreneurial and franchising is
that I mean every decision I make
touches that bottom line
and that's no different than if I'd
started a business where I complete
control over the creative - at the end
of the day that's you are dealing an
environment where you never have total
control over your environment and we
have our set of constraints that are
different than the constraints the
franchisor feels you know but Evans got
constraints ultimately it's did I create
the entity and do I live off its bottom
line and that is intensely satisfied
what works its intensely frustrating
what it doesn't yeah I mean I would
agree yeah it's completely
entrepreneurial and you own it you're
paid making the payroll you're doing all
that I mean my mom like you're she loved
it I was at HP she didn't want me off
like being a tutor but but I felt the
other way around I was so much more
proud to say I had my own thing so I
mean it depends in part on what your own
own direction is and related to you know
working for the man or having watched
some of the Iowa debates I'll use that
to get my own soundbite in then you know
we realized some of the point Gregg made
in terms of the importance of the
franchisor and one of the ways you can
evaluate that as many of the franchisee
particularly those that have a fewer the
master-builders is what is the franchise
owners association you know that's going
to tell you what the relationship is
with the franchisor is it adversarial
are they working together because
there's you know an innate conflict
there they make their money off the top
line you make it off the bottom line and
unless I look those lines are different
places and so their motivation is to get
you in increased sales regardless of
whether it increases your profits and so
I think it's very important when you're
evaluating what you found a concept is
to again find out what the relationship
is with the franchisor to not only meet
the people so you can judge them because
I believe you know math term I mean it's
necessary but not sufficient to have a
great franchise or if you don't have a
great franchisor talk can be almost
impossible for you to thrive if you do
have one and it's up to you and they
give you that opportunity but that's
where I'd spend the time and find the
reality I mean you can see are there
lawsuits
what's the turnover
choices there's a number of ways to
evaluate the reality of the quality of
the franchise or just also the quality I
mean there are as most of you probably
know already there are downsides to
being a franchisee right so I mean I
can't speak for the other ones but but
you know there's certainly you know
constraints that they impose on the
business with respect to the brand what
kind of products you sell you know the
the kinds of programs you can run but
and of course and there's this tax that
they levy on you right so you know which
I used to wrestle with all the time
right because you know I end up paying
this monstrous franchise royalty to the
creamery which you know for the first
three months I would say is absolutely
deserved because I could not have done
any of that without them but then beyond
the first three months I mean the
reality is I don't need them for a whole
lobby side sort of you know overhead
marketing support and I feel like you
know sometimes I can keep them in a bad
mood I'll convince myself that it's
absurd how much I'm paying them but but
what I have to come that back to is none
of this would have been possible without
them I mean if you're paying more than
just sort of the marginal support that
they're giving you from corporate I mean
you're paying for you know a lot for all
the risk reduction that they've given
you by tweaking the console finding
something that really works and
constantly trying to make the concept
better and share that across the system
so I mean it's clearly the other trade
off and yeah I would just point out that
in a system like Applebee's you're you
can view the royalty as payment for
ownership of the brand which is already
proven therefore you're buying into sort
of an asset they own I don't look at it
that way and I believe that they do for
me what I would otherwise have to do at
a much lower cost then then I if I did
it by myself so you know it's not paying
for a past asset it is everyday getting
what I need cheaper than I could do it
myself
white mark advertised developing
creative product development I mean the
Applebee's menu is 70 percent new in the
last two years where they have a huge
department that does that I want to deal
with that that it costs so much money to
do that sort of the definition of is it
a good franchise if you're happy that
they are doing that more effectively
than you can it's good
we'll see in a couple years how you're
still feeling and if you're still
worried and if you're in the Burger King
system the franchisees are constantly
moaning about how they're pissing away
their money they don't feel it's
well-spent at all and that they could do
it for themselves better they're wrong
by the way but that's what they say I'll
tell you that on our website actually on
Anita's in here but if there isn't now
there will be in a couple days I'll link
to some different resources on
franchises one of the things I found
when I was kind of fishing around
entrepreneur magazine on their website
has some really good guidelines on
things you should do when looking at a
franchise including questions that you
ask a franchisee so I suggest you take a
look there before you open it the
questions one other thing I decided to
last spring we did a program I know some
of you were there more from the
franchisor perspective we had Hilton and
franchise attorney there and it's
actually available for viewing those of
you who aren't GSB alumni and pourcel
you can't see it but err corrector from
lifelong learning has it set up and you
can actually view it online again link
from our website so it gives you
slightly different twist of it but
before we open it to questions which
we'll do in a few minutes anything else
in particular you guys want to add I
mean the one thing I'll say in closing
before we open up the Q & A is that if I
had known then what I know now I
probably if I could have sort of if I
could have cobbled together the
resources I would have done this a long
time ago you know it's amazing like
people my class and you know all the way
down through even like current clout you
know the current Shakespear's I mean
it's amazing how many people have
literally come out of the closet so you
know I'm really interested in doing
something like this but whether it
whether it's a sigma that's prevented
them from doing it or whether they just
need to think they could do it or
whether people would just get it back
and I should go out and absorb the
opportunity cost for doing it but but
what I mean I think the great thing is
people now see that you know people with
all kind of background go out and do
this and you know the whole package as
far as how liberating it is how
exhilarating is the economics are
fabulous and if you pick the right
concept you execute while you pick the
right location I mean that alone I think
it's something that people just tend to
under appreciate and how how well these
things can do I mean if money means
anything to so I definitely think that
if it's some that you
have unless you're absolutely committed
to an idea or go into a particular
industry and you've had your heart set
on that for your whole life I would say
definitely you know open yourself up to
doing something like this because I
think it combines a lot of the elements
that you know attract us to the GSB to
begin with